[Musique]
et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
anè Fermain leobudo bonjour merci d'être
avec nous ministre délégué chargé de
l'organisation territoriale et des
professions de santé vous êtes également
porte-parole d'horizon c'est le parti
d'Édouard Philippe on est ensemble
pendant 20 minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse régionale
représentée par Julien l'Écuyer de la
voie du Nord bonjour B Julien bonjour
Orian bonjour madame la ministre bonjour
on a beaucoup de sujets à aborder avec
vous et beaucoup de dossiers évidemment
agès FM lebudau mais d'abord on va
revenir sur le projet de loi immigration
puisque le Sénat ça y est l' a voté
mardi dans une version durcie par la
majorité sénatoriale qui a notamment
supprimé l'aide médicale d'État remplacé
par une aide médicale d'urgence est-ce
que vous souhaitez que les députés
rétablissent cette aide médicale d'État
telle qu'elle existait où est-ce qu'il
vaut mieux vous les appelez à aménager
le dispositif pour faciliter le
compromis après avec le Sénat écoutez de
façon très claire la ligne que j'ai
porté au nom du Gouvernement sur le banc
du Sénat il y a quelques jours était de
rappeler que le gouvernement tient au
dispositif de l'Ame parce que nous le
redisons l'aide médicale d'État dite ame
et bien un objet de santé publique il
est d'ailleurs inscrit dans le code de
l'action sociale et des familles donc
c'est bien un enjeu de santé publique
qui repose sur trois piliers d'abord
l'humain nous traitons des des hommes et
des femmes euh l'enjeu autour de la
santé publique parce que c'est bien un
objet de santé publique et puis d'une
logique aussi
économique donc Laim et ça a été dit
n'est pas un outil d'attractivité de
tourisme médical comme certains le
laissent penser et ce sujet n'avait rien
à faire puisque c'est un objet de santé
publique dans le Pro vous êtes même pas
prêt à des aménagements donc je continue
euh mais puisqu'on voit bien que depuis
maintenant plusieurs années euh j'étais
encore au banc au mois de mai puisque
cette fois-ci euh à l'Assemblée
nationale il y avait un projet de
résolution pour faire évoluer la me euh
ce sujet depuis des années euh sucite
des fantasmes euh et donc le
Gouvernement a souhaité confier une
mission à Patrick stéphanini et à Claudé
vin pour voir si il y avait des
aménagements à faire sur C tête médicale
d'État je rappelle quand même néanmoins
que nous avions déjà lors de la dernière
mandature fait des aménagements puisque
nous avions déjà réformé le panier de
soins augmenté les contrôles et je tiens
à dire que laame est le dispositif le
plus contrôlé par la Sécurité Sociale
pourquoi pourquoi est prévu le rendu du
du rapport donc l'avis de sagesse que le
gouvernement a émis c'était un avis de
sagesse de cohérence puisque nous avions
confié cette
mission à Patrick stéphanini et à
claudvin la moindre des choses c'est
d'attendre les rapports de la mission
avant éventuellement de faire des
aménagement donc on a déjà un prérapport
qui dit que le dispositif est utile qui
a pas il y a pas de souci d'attractivité
a pas de du coup est-ce que ça veut dire
que rien ne changera ou non bah non ben
ça pour le coup c'est bien pour ça que
nous avons émis un avis de sagesse sans
préjuger du tout du compte-rendu de de
cette mission la la première commande
avait été de nous rendre le rapport au
mois de janvier le débat à l'Assemblée
nationale arrivant avant h il on leur a
demandé d'accélérer un petit peu et ce
rapport sera remis juste avant le débat
à l'Assemblée nationale donc juste avant
le 11 décemb donc le gouvernement oui le
gouvernement n'est pas fermé a des
évolutions si des préconisations sont
faites en ce sens mais nous le redisons
transformer l'ame en Amu serait une
erreur vraiment à la fois en terme de
santé publique mettrait sur les hôpitaux
une charge supplémentaire dont les
hôpitaux n'ont pas besoin ça c'est
vraiment absolument nécessaire de le
redire et qu'on soit clair la position
du gouvernement à l'Assemblée sera celle
du rapport ou pas on ne préjuge pas non
mais on ne préjuge pas on ne Prée pas du
rapport mais nous ne sommes pas fermés
du coup à des évolutions à des
évolutions si Patrick stéphanem et
claudvin nous nous préconiseent des
évolutions comment vous réagissez à la
tribune qui a été signée par 3500
médecins pour justement défendre cette
aide médicale j'ai trouvé ça d'abord
très intéressant que des soignants
disent à quel point l'ame est un enjeu
de santé publique et quand on regarde
les soignants il y avait j'allais dire
des soignants de tous horizons euh et
j'ai trouvé que cet appui était pas
forcément
le j'ai trouvé ça intéressant je crois
que c'est la première fois que ça se
fait euh et et on est d'abord passé à
3000 puis 3500 soignants qui ont
souhaité dire à quel point il
était dangereux dangereux de transformer
l'amee en Amu parce qu'il était aussi
important que la médecine de ville
puisse prendre en
charge mais vous entendez ce que répond
Bruno il dit qu'avant 99 il y avait pas
de problème de santé publique
qu'ailleurs en Europe le dispositif est
plus restreint qu'il y a pas de problème
de santé publique alors d'ailleurs en
Europe le le le dispositif n'est pas
plus restreint que que laame est bien un
dispositif qui permet du contrôle
supprimer laame c'est en Espagne où le
dispositif a été supprimé pendant un
certain temps ils sont revenus dessus
parce que on perd je dire on perd le
contrôle et ça permet aussi c'est un
enjeu de santé publique he soigner les
pathologies aigues c'est mieux que de
d'atteindre des complications on prend
souvent l'engine l'engine c'est mieux de
soigner une ville une engine en ville
que de voir quelqu'un arriver à
l'hôpital pour un flgment donc l'idée
c'est mieux de traiter le plus tôt
possible et ça c'est valable pour tous
nos concitoyens aussi Julien une
dernière question sur l'immigration sur
l'immigration oui puisque l'article sur
les régularisations aussi dans les
métiers en tenstion une mesure de pH du
du texte a été nettement restreinte sa
procédure reviendrait finalement à la
main des des des des préfets à sorti de
conditions tellement multiples que elle
réduit énormément le le contingent
probable c'est satisfaisant pour
vous là aussi faut je dire faut faut de
la cohérence donc l'accord a été trouvé
sur ce cette dispositif qui est
important on voit bien qu'il y a
beaucoup de métiers en tension je vais
revenir sur le domaine de la santé et
notamment les praticiens hors Union
européenne nous avions proposé dans le
cadre de de ce projet de loi
immigration de faire une carte talent
métier métier de santé là aussi sur le
principe on est d'accord les
républicains étaient d'accord mais n'ont
pas accepté cette carte talent parce
qu'il y avait dans cette carte talent un
regroupement familial faire venir des
praticiens hors Union européenne ce sont
des hommes et des femmes qui ont déjà
fait leur vie qui ont 40 45 ans et donc
une famille a priori une famille a
priori ou pas c'est pas grave mais
l'idée c'est de vraiment les s'ils
souhaitent venir en France les
accueillir aussi avec leur famille donc
tout ça a été j'allais dire restreint
dans le temps avec le dispositif de
passer des examens et ben non parce
qu'il y a juste le regroupement familial
là aussi on dit que c'est un appel
d'air à l'immigration mais les mêmes
vous demande dans d'autres temps de
faire venir le maximum de praticiens
hors Union Européenne la demande de
Monsieur monsieur Juvin de Monsieur
marlex par exemple voilà donc il sert
cohérents à droite je je pense que c'est
pas tout à fait cohérent voilà c'est
juste ce que je veux dire je donne juste
un exemp plus diplomatique en effet on
va parler de la fin de vie il y a une
réunion de cadrage qui aurait dû se
tenir mardi avec le président de la
République sur ce sujet elle a été
reportée vous avez une date non pas
encore mais là aussi je pense qu'il faut
arrêter les les analyses sur des dates
et des histoires d'agenda le président
de la République le 3 avril dernier a
demandé au gouvernement de travailler à
l'écriture d'un projet de loi euh pour
construire le modèle français
d'accompagnement de la fin de vie c'est
ce que nous avons fait après beaucoup de
travail sur un sujet aussi difficile que
celui-là il faut prendre le temps c'est
ce que nous avons fait également nous
continuons à travailler notamment sur la
stratégie décennale des soins palliatifs
on va pas faire le lien entre une date
reporté et euh j'allais dire le progrès
et la loi de progrès qui l'pportera
c'est pas le signe qui l'avance à
reculon sur c'est pas le signe qui
avance à reculon juste faire le
parallèle avec l'agenda qui depuis
septembre l'agenda que ce soit en terme
de géopolitique en terme d'intempérie
voilà on va pas faire le comparatif
entre un décalage de date sur un agenda
et la volonté de vouloir avancer sur ce
sujet c'est vraiment j'entends madame
ministre mais il y a quand même
excusez-nous he une sorte de flou qui
qui persiste à la fois sur le calendrier
bon on peut l'expliquer il y a eu la
visite papal aussi qui qui a pu altérer
le le calendrier de de votre projet de
loi on l'attendait quand même à à la fin
de l'été il a pas été déposé on attend
encore et même sur la méthode on
s'interroge on s'interroge toujours
puisqu'on ne sait pas si ça peut passer
au Parlement ou si ça va être la voix du
peuple qui va être privilégé sur le
référendum puisque c'est c'est votre
question actuellement pour pouvoir
passer par référendum il faudrait
modifier la Constitution là ce serait le
un choix c'est pas le choix qui a été
fait je le redis le choix qui a été fait
c'est de bien demander au gouvernement
de travailler sur un projet de loi ce
projet de loi il a été travaillé nous
avons encore des aménagements à faire à
la marche cétait l'objet de la réunion
avec le président de la République et
j'aurais été accompagné de de trois
autres ministres sur sur ce sujet euh là
on est bien dans une histoire de
calendrier je je le répète euh le
président de la République mardi était
au côté dans le Pas de Calais voilà
l'agenda du président va au gré aussi
j'allais dire de la situationun texte
qui était promis avant le 21 septembre
on se retrouve bientôt à l'hiver on on
voit toujours pas la coule un texte qui
était je je le redis avant la fin de
l'été c'était remise au président de la
République ce qui devait passer en
conseil des ministres fin septembre ou
début octobre non non non non non
c'était remise remise au président de la
République du texte non non je vais pas
jouer sur les mots c'est clairement ce
qui éé demandé on nous on nous on nous a
clairement annoncé qui qui qu'il
arrivera en conseil des ministres à C
prie je le redis l'agenda l'agenda
depuis la rentrée en terme de
géopolitique en terme de d'intempérie
est malheureusement j'allais dire
conséquent mais du coup il arrive quand
au Conseil des ministres assez vite dès
que dès que le dès que nous avons pouvu
j'allais dire dès que nous avons pu les
quatre ministres qui devaient participer
à la réunion de mardi et le président de
la République faire les derniers
arbitrages décembre ou pas pas forcément
touours ça peut être ça peut être en
2024 de toute façon le le texte devait
arriver au Parlement en 2024 oui mais
bon au Conseil pas forcément comme vous
dites c'est pas encore stabilisé parce
que vous parliez d'arbitrage on a cru
comprendre que le le président de la
République lu même avait des
interrogations sur l'exception de de
d'euthanasie est-ce que vous nous dites
encore quels sont les points encore sur
lesquels il faut justement s'accorder on
a à la fois sur la stratégiecénale
encore à puisque l'idée c'est de de de
faire en sorte aussi que ce que nous
allons proposer sur les soins palliatifs
sur 10 ans j'allais dire soit réalisable
tant en terme de de professionnel de
santé qu'en terme de budget donc nous
sommes encore en train de travailler sur
ces sujets et puis je vous le redis
c'est des réunions d'arbitrage sur la
façon dont on va faire évoluer ce droit
cet accès à l'aide à mourir c'est
l'objet des des réunions que nous allons
avoir avec le président de la République
mais est-ce que dans le texte ilura le
mot eutanasie dans le projet de loi
permettrai de pas vous répondre à cet
instant mais je je je l'ai déjà dit la
réponse c'est non la voix du référendum
c'est pour vous une bonne chose je pense
qu'inroger nos concitoyens c'est
toujours une bonne chose euh est-ce que
sur un sujet aussi difficile que
celui-là on peut trouver la bonne
question qui permettent de répondre
euh de répondre vraiment à un sujet qui
est je je le redis qui touche à l'intime
de chacun et qui est vraiment très
compliqué pour avoir beaucoup travaillé
sur le sujet je leur dis avoir travaillé
avec des soignants avec des
parlementaires avoir beaucoup consulté
c'est un sujet qui est vraiment très
très compliqué et on voit bien que la
question du OUI ou du non sur un sujet
comme celui-là si la question c'est
est-ce que il faut que la loi évolue sur
la fin de vie éolue mais après je je je
et là c'est pour ça que c'est difficile
aussi de de de sur le modèle choisi on
voit bien d'ailleurs que autour de nous
il y a différents modèles choisis par
différents pays donc ça dépend vraiment
de la question sur un sujet comme
celui-là je la question à poser à
répondre par oui ou par non n'est pas si
simple que ça est-ce que on parle juste
d'une évolution du de du du principe
parce que c'est un sujet de société
c'est clairement un sujet de société et
les nombreux débats que je fais auquels
je participe et encore et je vais encore
en continuer à faire vois bien me montre
à quel point je crois que la société est
vraiment prête à évoluer mais tout le
monde s'interroge et c'est légitime mais
donc excusez-moi mais pour pour résumer
votre positionnement c'est réticence
vis-à-vis du référendum du fait de la
difficulté de la question en en
elle-même donc plutôt privilégier le
débat parlementaire je crois ouais sur
un sujet comme celui-là vraiment c'est
c'est vraiment c'est vraiment très très
compliqué hein par parce que on voit
bien et et le débat parlementaire aussi
permettra d'enrchir le texte c'est le
rôle des parlementaires euh et pourant
le président continue travail juste
pardon avec les groupes parlementaires
ça vous continuer ru depuis depuis on va
continuer le travail bien sûr pardon
Julien non mais pourtant le le le
président va va proposer cette réflexion
à aux rencontres de Saint-Denis demain
l'ouverture du du champ du référendum
peut-être sur la question de la fin de
vie sur les non peut-être sur les
questions de société c'est pas tout à
fait la même
chose la fin de vie la fin de vie fait
partie des questions de société je dis
que moi je suis pas contre le principe
la difficulté sur un sujet comme
celui-là c'est qu'on voit bien que on ne
peut pas répondre à la question
uniquement par euh est-ce que vous
voulez l'euthanasie ou est-ce que vous
voulez le subcide assister franchement
je pour avoir beaucoup travaillé le
sujet c'est pas si simple que ça Jul un
mot sur ces rencontres de saint-onis oui
la question alors non on a vu que le le
le PS et les filles et maintenant LR par
la voix de derck cotti ont refusé
l'invitation du du du président pour
vous c'est une faute c'est une erreur
sans aucun doute
euh d'abord alors où on se pose la
question de l'enjeu de la démocratie
des valeurs de la République lorsqu'un
président de la République invite les
forces politiques à discuter je crois
comme ça d'ailleurs été le cas lors de
la première réunion qu'il est important
d'accepter le principe d'une discussion
ça s'appelle la démocratie c'est plutôt
c'est plutôt
intéressant noter que trois partis ont
fait ont fait le choix de de ne pas
venir et ben je trouve que c'est c'est
plutôt une erreur oui h Julien on va
parler de l'état de santé des soignants
oui l'État santé des soignants qui est
préoccupant hein qui doit devenir une
priorité stratégique du système de santé
c'est ça c'est la conclusion d'un d'un
rapport qui est qui vous a été remis il
y a un mois une feuille de route est
attendue en en décembre alors est-ce que
vous pouvez au moins nous dire quelles
pistes sont explorées à l'heure actuelle
alors on voit bien que sur les enjeux
des problématiques autour de la
démographie médicale euh j'ai j'ai
souhaité dès l'entrée de mon ministère
travailler sur deux sujets sur
l'attractivité et la fidélisation des
professions de santé d'abord la sécurité
des professionnels de santé et la santé
des professionnels de santé en sortie de
crise sanitaire peut-être le prisme de
mon métier de de pharmacien euh m'a
montré à quel point les professionnels
de santé ne prenez pas soin de leur
santé le premier travail que nous avons
fait c'était de de les interroger 55000
réponses euh 75 % disent ne pas bien
dormir 50 % disent avoir fait un burnout
il nous semblait 38 % disent ne pas bien
manger 60 % souffrent de douleur
chronique un/ers admet ne pas avoir une
alimentation saine on pourrait
multiplier les chiffres visiblement donc
donc visiblement nos professionnels de
santé ne vont pas bien donc j'ai confié
une mission à Philippe de Normandie
euh praticien hospitalier euh marine
Crest médecin généraliste et Alexis
bataille
infirmier militaire euh l'idée c'était
vraiment de de de leur demander de
travailler à la fois sur les soignants
en ville et sur les soignants dans les
établissements ils m'ont remis un
rapport intéressant avec des pistes
d'amélioration euh et surtout des pistes
de travail sur le et donc ces pistes
alors donc on va en décembre donner une
feuille de route une feuille de route
avec des objets autour bien sûr de la
prévention d'amélioration de la qualité
de V au travail mais c'est pas vraiment
l'objet uniquement du rapport et de
permettre aux professionnels de se
soigner on a vu qu'il y a des choses qui
existent très bien d'abord aussi de se
former à sa propre santé et de lever le
tabou de lever le tabou sur le dénis de
prendre soin de sa santé parce que on a
peur du regard du confrère notamment à
l'hôpital euh l'hôpital Foch a développé
un dispositif qui est un centre de santé
pour les soignants euh qui assez
intéressant où les soignants sont vus
par d'autres professionnels que ceux qui
travaillent par exemple à l'hôpital donc
cette feuille de route elle sera
présenté en décembre on réfléchit aussi
aux soignants de ville des professions
libérales qui n'ont pas de médecine du
travail ça veut dire que le médecin d'un
médecin c'est soit lui-même c'est jamais
une bonne idée est plus mal chaussé soit
parfois le collègue euh d'à côté c'est
pas une bonne idée non plus l'idée c'est
vraiment de proposer de proposer des
nouveaux dispositifs et surtout de faire
prendre conscience qu'il est important
de prendre soin de sa santé d'améliorer
la prise donc de créer de créer une
médecine du travail des médecins de leur
offrir la possibilité d'aller dans une
médecine de travail d'avoir des
rendez-vous systématiques là aussi je
pense que c'est important la prise de
conscience que un professionnel de santé
qui va bien est un profess de santé qui
soigne bien l'une de vos missions agè FM
le baudau pas simple c'est aussi deett
mettre fin au déserts médicaux
l'association des mères ruraux a publié
une étude cette semaine disant que
l'espérance de vie en milieu rural est
de 2 ans plus courte que pour les gens
qui habitent en ville et que c'est
largement lié aux difficultés d'accès
aux professionnels de santé comment vous
avez réagi à cette étude l'association
des mères ruraux l'année dernière avait
fait aussi une étude sur ce sujet-là en
disant que les déserts médicaux étaient
plus importants dans les territoires
ruraux que que que en ville euh on voit
bien que les difficultés d'accès c'est
aux médecins évidemment qui sont au
professionnels de santé d'ailleurs
élargis qui sont pas plus prignants en
milieu rural puisque le plus grand
déserts médical c'est l'île-de-fance
euh non mais là il a dans l'étude ils
disent qu'il y a moins de recours au son
hospitaliers VI c'est moins moins facile
parce qu'il y a moins il y a moins
notamment en terme de proximité euh de
de service de spécialité comme vous le
dites donc potentiellement
statistiquement moins de chance et donc
c'est bien pour ça est important et
c'est bien pour ça que les hôpitaux de
proximité les hôpitaux périphériques ont
été développés c'est bien pour ça que
nous avons construit des plan de allz
vert le plan des médicobus qui permettra
d'aller ver et notamment dans les
territoires ruraux les plus reculés dans
lesquels il n'y a plus de professionnels
parce que les professionnels ne veulent
plus s'installer tout seul donc le
développement des 4000 maisons de santé
pluriprofessionnelles qui permettent à
plusieurs professionnel et notamment
dans les territoires ruraux de pouvoir
s'installer ensemble de travailler
ensemble et là aussi de développer le à
les ver tous ces objets là sont
maintenant construits puisque j'ai
présenté en juin quatre points qui vont
nous permettre de répondre en partie et
qui pour vous sont suffisants parce que
eu eux ils disent par exemple il
faudrait un guidchet unique au niveau du
département pour accompagner
l'installation des professionnels de s
ça a été voté c'est proposer voilà après
il y a tout l'objet autour de
l'attractivité et comment on accompagne
les professionnels à s'installer c'était
c'est l'objet de la plateforme c'est
aussi l'objet de la maison de santé
plurépressionnelle c'est tout de suite
on met à disposition quelqu'un qui
accompagner les professionnels pour
construire ses projets parce qu'on sait
bien que c'est pas le métier d'un
médecin la volonté c'est vraiment
d'accompagner dès le début les jeunes
médecins pour s'installer et les
professionnels quand ils ont des projets
pour monter leur projets en tout cas
c'est l'accompagnement qui prime à
l'heure actuelle mais si vous ne voyez
pas de résultat il y a pas le comment
dire l'idée d'une d'une contrainte
d'aller plus loin le gouvernement là
aussi une position très claire sur ce
sujet 87 % de la France est un désert
médical là aussi à l'instant où je vous
parle faut sortir j' dire des fantasmes
où il y aurait des endroits très
surdotés
87 % de la France est un désert médical
donc il y a des endroits effectivement
où il y a un tout petit peu plus de
médecins qu'ailleurs il faut entendre
aussi ce que nous disent les médecins
regardez ce qui s'est fait dans les pays
voisin ceux qui ont essayé la régulation
la coerciss l'obligation reviennent sur
ces mesures parce que ça ne marche pas
euh et c'est votre parti qui avait
alerté des parlementaires de votre parti
qui avaient alerté en disant il va
falloir prendre des mesures de
cooherition parce que si on continue sur
les déser médicau c'est un carburant
pour le rassemblement national non alors
dire qu'on va résoudre les déserts
médicaux à partir moment o 87 % de la
France c'est un désert médical avec la
régulation bien que ça marche pas ça
aurait même les effets contraires ce que
nous disent d'abord les jeunes médecins
vous si vous m'obligez on arrête on
arrête on ne pratri pas on fera autre
chose ù on ira à l'étranger ce que
certains commencent à faire les médecins
retraités qui souhaitent continuer
notamment grâce la mise en place de
dispositif cumulant pour la retraite à
vouloir exercer si vous leur dites vous
vous allez faire votre journée de
vacation à 150 km de chez vous ça ne
marche pas non plus ils ne font pas donc
on perd des chances de pouvoir embarquer
avec nous soit des jeunes professionnels
qui souhaitent s'installer soit des
médecins retraités l'enjeu du
déconventionnement qui est aussi un
enjeu qui serait délétaire sur l'accès
aux soins et je le répète la protection
sociale la solidarité c'est bien aussi
ça que nous défendons donc dire c'est un
manque de responsabilité pour vous des
médecins qui se déconventionnent bah
c'est-à-dire que on on ne permet pas le
rembours donc c'est un peu plus
compliqué c'est pas un manque de
responsabilité c'est un choix mais le
risque le risque d'une régulation ça
vis-àis des Français bah notamment oui
c'est c'est un risque c'est un risque de
voir queun partie de nos concitoyens là
aussi on recrée des difficultés d'accès
au soins parce que certains de nos
concitoyens n'ont pas les moyens de
payer une consultation qui ne serait pas
remboursée donc si on fait le cumul de
tous ces dispositifs on voit bien qu'à
l'heure où on se parle à partir du
moment où 87 % de la France est un
désert bical nous n'avons pas assez de
professionnels de santé je dis de santé
de façon
globale imposer des mesures serait
contreproductif nous le pensons vraiment
très sincèrement et je crois qu'il est
important d'écouter et de regarder aussi
ce qui se fait et vous dites quand même
au médecins de de prendre leur
responsabilités ils vont être aidés
accompagnés jusqu'à un certain points
mais il faut que quand même que chez eux
il y ait une part de responsabilité par
rapport à la situation ils l'ont déjà je
je je le redis les médecins ne sont pas
responsabl de ce qui se passe
actuellement je veux dire les décisions
elles ont été prises il y a plusieurs
années nous n'avons ont pas pris assez
tôt la mesure de suppression du numéros
closus qui est en partie responsable de
cette situation on sait qu'on va avoir
encore 8 ans très difficile c'est pas
pour ça qu'il ne faut rien faire c'est
l'objet des quatre plans que nous avons
présenté c'est aussi l'objet des travaux
que nous menons avec les professionnels
pour
les les délégations de tâche ou les
transferts de compétences par exemple ça
c'est un travail important mais qui sera
aussi bénéfique quand nous aurons plus
de professionnels c'est-à-dire dans 8
ans et dans 10 ans merci an fir lebodo
merci beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité
ce matin Julien la Une de La Voix du
Nord ce sont les inondations évidemment
pied dans l'eau tête haute tête haute
avec les portraits de de de secouristes
de bénévoles qui ont aidé à affronter
les intempéries c'est à la une de la
voie du Nord merci Julien merci Madame
la Ministre on passe au club des
territoires